Robert Downey Jr.'s Iron Man went through
a profound journey in Avengers: Endgame and
delivered an unforgettable line that was a
touching callback to the very beginning of
the Marvel movie franchise.
As it turns out, that iconic moment almost
never happened… because Downey Jr. reportedly
didn't want to say Tony Stark's last major
line.
Even though co-directors Joe and Anthony Russo
lifted the ban on spoilers for Avengers: Endgame,
we're offering you one last warning: Major
spoilers ahead!
And now for the juicy details.
During a recent appearance on CinemaBlend's
ReelBlend podcast, the Russo brothers opened
up about Tony's final scene in Avengers: Endgame.
As you might recall, the hero equipped his
own suit with the Infinity Stones, snapped
his fingers, and promptly turned Thanos and
his minions into space dust.
Right before Tony mirrored Thanos' Decimation
from Infinity War, the Mad Titan was clearly
convinced that he had the upper hand, proudly
proclaiming:
"I am inevitable."
But in a move displaying all the dry, cool,
wit that makes Tony who he is - he flashed
his hand to show Thanos he had the Infinity
Stones - and then he said it:
"I am Iron Man."
Of course, the line is a callback to the end
of 2008's Iron Man.
"I am Iron Man."
Sadly, the Snap takes a toll on Tony's body,
and he dies shortly after that.
He manages to speak a few more words before
passing away… and then we get to hear him
one more time in a heartwarming message that
he recorded prior to his death.
But Tony's last big line is this proud assertion
of his heroism.
But hold everything.
As Joe and Anthony Russo tell it, Tony originally
didn't say those words at all.
In fact, he originally didn't say anything
in that moment.
An early cut of the film simply had Tony snap
his fingers, and that was that.
Enter Avengers: Endgame editor Jeff Ford,
who pitched the idea of having Tony say:
"I am Iron Man."
Once they heard the concept, the Russo brothers
knew they had to reshoot the scene with that
line included.
But apparently Downey Jr. was initially uneasy
with the idea.
It took some convincing before he finally
agreed to do a reshoot.
As Joe Russo revealed:
"I had dinner with him like two weeks before
we were supposed to shoot it.
And he was like, 'I don't know.
I don't really want to go back and get into
that emotional state.'"
Joe Russo goes on to explain that producer
Joel Silver is a close personal pal of Downey
Jr.'s, and he just so happened to be eating
with them.
According to Joe, Silver enthusiastically
blurted out:
"'Robert, what are you talking about?
That's the greatest line I've ever heard!
You gotta say this line!
You have to do this!'"
Once Downey Jr. was on board, the crew reportedly
headed back to the studio to reshoot the scene.
As we said before, the newly-added line served
as a touching nod to the very beginning of
the MCU.
But the whole reshooting process turned out
to be a callback to Downey Jr.'s humble beginnings
as Iron Man.
As Anthony Russo explains:
"The stage that we shot that shot on was adjacent
to the stage where Robert Downey Jr. screen
tested for Iron Man."
Well… if that doesn't give you chills, we
don't know what will.
Downey Jr. might have been wary about stepping
back into character for the powerful scene,
but we're so glad he ultimately came around.
The final line he shot is easily one of the
most memorable moments in the entire film.
And, as many fans can attest, Avengers: Endgame
just wouldn't have been the same without Tony
Stark going out with a bang… and a biting
remark.
That's sort of his calling card, you know?
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more exclusive Looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.